in his fourth conversation with the
israeli prime minister since the current
violence began
u.s president joe biden said he expected
a significant
and immediate de-escalation on a path to
a ceasefire
it was the most assertive language
toward israel publicly used by the white
house
but it was clearly rebuffed as the
bombardment of gaza
continued the israeli leadership
understands that this is ultimately a
bluff that there's not going to be
action put
where there are only words and therefore
they are crea they are
completely free to carry on with their
massive assault against gaza civilian
population that is absolutely
devastating the united states has so far
resisted
international pressure to join other
world leaders
in calling for an immediate ceasefire
despite pressure
also building from within in washington
liberal members of biden's own party
urged the u.s to take a stronger stance
i believe we must stand in solidarity
with those palestinians and israelis
working to build a future of equality
and peaceful coexistence
and not with the intolerant extremists
on either side who wish to destroy that
future
in this moment of crisis the united
states should be urging
an immediate ceasefire a group of
democratic members of congress
introduced a house resolution calling
for the u.s
to halt the sale of 735 million dollars
in guided missiles to israel
representative rashida talib tweeted
no more weapons to kill children and
families enough
and representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez wrote
the united states should not be rubber
stamping weapon sales to the israeli
government
as they deploy our resources to target
international media outlets
schools hospitals humanitarian missions
and civilian sites for bombing we have a
responsibility to protect human rights
the resolution to block the arms sales
to israel is
non-binding and unlikely to advance in
congress
where support for israel among
republicans and many democrats
remain strong but among liberals the
growing sense that
israel should be held to account and u.s
support
cannot be unconditional heidi joe castro
al jazeera washington